earlier this week President Trump took
decisive action to call on Turkish
forces to stand down to end the violence
to agree to negotiations and today I'm
proud to report thanks to the strong
leadership of President Donald Trump and
the strong relationship between
president air Dewan and Turkey and the
United States of America that today the
United States and Turkey have agreed to
a ceasefire in Syria Turkish side will
pause operation peace spring in order to
allow for the withdrawal of YPG forces
from the safe zone for 120 hours all
military operations under Operation
peace spring will be paused and
Operation peace spring will be halted
entirely on completion of the withdrawal
our administration has already been in
contact with Syrian defense forces and
we have already begun to facilitate
their safe withdrawal from the nearly 20
mile wide safe zone area south of the
Turkish border in Syria let me say this
also includes an agreement by Turkey to
engage in no military action against the
community of kobani and in addition the
United States and Turkey have both
mutually committed to a peaceful
resolution and future for the safe zone
working on an international basis to
ensure that peace and security defines
this border region of Syria in addition
to the settlement today with the
ceasefire turkey in the United States
mutually committed to the defeat Isis
activities in Northeast Syria
this will also include an agreement
renewed today to coordinate efforts on
detention facilities in internally
displaced persons in formerly Isis
controlled areas also Turkey and the
United States agreed on the priority of
respecting vulnerable human life human
rights and particularly the protection
of religious and ethnic communities in
the region